hey guys today we're examining the more
interesting details that you may have
missed
from my academia chapter 286.
as usual the official translations have
clarified a few things
especially the words of nana shimura
during that final panel
but we'll get to that later just before
we jump into it
i have some exciting news which is that
i now have a twitch account
and every sunday at midday eastern time
i'll be doing a live analysis to the new
chapters
the first stream will be this sunday and
we'll be discussing my hero chapter 287
and black clover chapter 267
also i will be on camera because it's
twitch so if you haven't seen my face
yet then you know that would be a good
time
if that sounds good then i'd love if you
pause this video for one second
and click the link in my description to
follow me on twitch
but with that said i hope to see you
there on sunday and
yeah let's just get into this video to
start things off
the name of this chapter is the ones
within us which is a reference to both
all for one inhabiting shigaraki's body
and the vestiges of one for all
inhabiting deku's quirk
this title is very different from the
unofficial fan translations
which called it one among us which
originally had me thinking that
harakoshi was playing
a certain game an interesting thing to
note is that after all for one took
over shiguraki's body in the last
chapter we now see shiggy
fighting back as the apprentice and
master battle each other
for control that's why in this panel we
can see his head shaking as shiggy tells
him to cut it out
despite this though afo does retain
control
and he removes the tentacles from force
quirk activation he removes them from
bakago's body
in the words of afo during the battle
today there's been a lot of blood
spilled for no reason
but remember it was only last chapter
that he truly tried to take over
shiguraki's body
so what this means is that he's been
watching since the very beginning and
he's literally just been
a bystander and is now only choosing to
step in because he felt
that shiguraki was going to lose we
always knew that the will
of author one was inside shigaraki but
we didn't actually think it was really
awful one himself just watching the
whole fight take place
but this right here is basically a
confirmation it does make me wonder
though
what exactly is happening to afo's body
that's in tartarus right now like is
that body still
active are there two afos right now or
is that body like just
not it's just unconscious right now and
he's in shigaraki's body
it's quite kind of confusing how this
works but i guess we'll find out
following this deku goes berserk yet
again and i gotta say i'm consistently
impressed by
harakoshi's range like the range of
angry deku faces it's so varied like i
love it
from midoriya's perspective shigaraki
has potentially killed
gran torino bakugo and izawa blood loss
is a real thing i mean izawa's lost his
leg
bakugou has been stabbed through the
stomach and shoulder and obviously gran
torino got impaled
so in real life there's a high chance of
death for all three of them
but because this is shown in manga i
reckon only
maximum one of them is going to die and
it's going to be gran torino
at present though deku doesn't actually
know he's in a manga
and so you know from his point of view
they could all die and we get this
beautiful spread of him just going crazy
biting in to the force quirk activation
tentacles and and destroying it
his right hand snaps it like it's
nothing and his left side looks like
he's punching the force quirk activation
head on i mean ridiculous stuff what was
especially cool about this moment
was we get a flashback to the words of
lariat who was the fifth user of one for
all
way back in the joint training arc
lariat said to deku
that if he uses the power out of anger
it will start
working for him a lot better he was
referring to black whip when he said
that
and we see in one of the later panels
that deku has all for one totally
surrounded
with black whip before we get that far
ahead though
a large crack appears across shigeraki's
face out of nowhere
deku hasn't done anything to cause this
specific crack
and remember shiguraki's body is
currently regenerating
so it's kind of weird that an injury
would suddenly appear this is then
followed up
by an image of all for one smiling
behind the crack
and in my opinion you know this is one
of the best pieces of art we've ever
seen in my
academia as i said in my spoiler review
for this chapter
afo appearing is more of a metaphor to
signify that he's now in control
because like i said he's not going to
burst out of shigaraki this is all just
you know to show you that he's in the
driver's seat one quick side note
we see that bits of skin they're
starting to break off shigaraki's face
which further proves that right now
shiggy's body is the crustiest it has
ever been and
that is some achievement moving on we
see giganto makia on an
absolute rampage just tearing up a city
and the big guy notes how he can smell
two distinct scents one of them being
shigaraki
and the other one being all for one i
found this to be strange because
it means that all for one's mind control
over shiguraki
it has a physical side effect as well
like otherwise machia would never
be able to smell him if i had to
speculate this could be foreshadowing
that all for one can literally
swap bodies with shigeraki and this is
my
quick theory here shiguraki's body will
transform
and kind of look like what all for one
used to look like back in his younger
days
we then get a look at the evacuation
happening in jakku
and essentially what's going on is that
the heroes and police
are now helping citizens to evacuate
before machia arrives
and someone is not clear who says this
but someone correctly points out
that the heroes at the battlefield like
endeavor and deku
they don't know that jaganta maki is
coming like no one's told them
because shiguraki destroyed the
communications
this means that in the coming chapters
more heroes should arrive to the main
battlefield
to tell deku and the gang of machias
impending arrival
i definitely think at the least ochaka
will be there because
the not only is the entire next page
dedicated to her thoughts
but in a previous chapter she literally
just said like she wants to go back and
help
similar to last week the two most
interesting things about this chapter
are located in its final pages number
one
is all for one stealing one for all
which is a big deal
and number two is the reappearance of
nana shimura
to start with the first point afo sticks
his hand directly in front of deku's
face
and we can see that the hole in his hand
does actually begin to suck out one for
all
this hole is specifically for taking
quirks and we see in the next panel
these lines they indicate the transfer
is happening
but that said i don't think this is the
end of it
we'll have to see but as many of you
know i'm not against the idea of one
floor being taken
in fact one of my most popular theories
one of the main points of that was one
fall
is gonna be taken um however if it is
stolen then i don't think this is the
moment
for it to happen for the sake of the
plot if it happened now the heroes are
actually done for because
everyone is tired everyone's beaten up
so if they get
if they get over one right now how do
the heroes make it out alive they don't
they don't make it out alive
so um yeah i think for plot sake it's
not going to happen right now
but it could happen in the future whilst
this transfer of one for all is
seemingly happening
deku is then transported to the vested
world and
when we compare him now to the first
time he entered this world
there is a big difference as i theorized
in my spoiler review
the more percentage of one fraud that he
unlocks the more that we're able to see
him
in this world alternatively it could
mean that the more quirks he unlocks the
more we see him
maybe maybe that one as well midorious
sees all for one
and shigaraki enter the vestige world of
one for all
and an interesting thing to notice is
that before they emerge
the ground looks pretty normal right but
after they come out we see
all the lines that usually happen when
shiguraki activates his decay quirk
these lines are also very similar to
when all for one was stealing one for
all a second ago
so based on whichever interpretation you
prefer
these lines mean that shiguraki is about
to destroy the vested world
or he's about to take it over as the new
holder of one for all
only time will tell but just know that
these lines are never a good thing
shiggy tells his master to stay back and
that you know he should be the one
running the show he's the successor
but all for one grabs him gently and
says that he had to help because
if he didn't shigaraki would have been
killed by endeavour's flames
and you know this is a fair point
because uh had all for one not activated
force quack activation
he probably would have been burnt up
completely from this text it seems like
all for one is genuinely trying to help
shigaraki
more than he's trying to betray him but
of course betrayal
is still on the cards deku collapses to
the ground
and it's at this point that we get to
see nana shimura
she tells midoriya that he can't move in
this world yet
and the fact that she says yet means
there's something deku can do in the
future
that will allow him to move around in
this world i highly doubt she's
referring to his death
at this point you know he's only a
teenager so i think she means that
there's something that's gonna happen
that will allow him to move around
she tells midoriya let us handle this
which means that she's not going to be
fighting alone
at a minimum i think nanashimura lariat
and all for one's brother will try and
stop all for one and shigaraki
from taking the quirk it's also possible
that the fourth user will join in
because
he's had some spotlight in recent
chapters with bakago questioning what
you know what almighty's hiding about
him
so um i think that could come into play
as well from what i'm seeing right now
it seems that in the next chapter or the
next few chapters
the previous users of one floor that i
just mentioned will try and defeat all
for one and shigaraki
inside this vestige world and that will
stop them from
taking one for all because i mean like i
said the transfer looked like it was
underway
so i guess the only way to stop it is to
defeat them within one for all i guess
nana shimura places her hand on the back
of deku's head
which is exactly what she did to
shigeraki when he was
getting all for one so um yeah it's an
interesting parallel
um but i guess unlike shigeraki deku is
actually gonna listen to what she has to
say
and yeah guys for chapter 286 that was
everything i had
be sure to follow me on twitch for a
live reaction to
the official release of chapter 287 is
happening this sunday
at 12 p.m eastern standard time and
until the next video
peace out